[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vais tester un jeu dont
l'univers n'a de secret pour personne
c'est à dire la ce battle ben quoi ça
vous dit rien bâle est ok d'accord et si
je vous demande ça alors
wasquehal
petit écran
[Musique]
ça
survivant de l'enfer
j'aime bien
souvent voir
le gars m'ont dit
les bandits
et oui là ce battle est tirée du célèbre
manga hokuto no ken plus connu chez nous
sous le nom de ken le survivant
bien sûr tout le monde connaît ken le
survivant depuis la diffusion paul émile
de la série rapport à la violence à la
fin des années 80 ou à cause de la
censure
un épisode passé de 22 à 15 minutes avec
du recul les doublages était aussi
épouvantable que charmant en fait le
caractère assez hardcore de la série rob
était vraiment les doubleurs et du coup
ils se sont mis en grève et de retenir
le taf qu'à la condition que ce soit eux
qui adapte les doubles à leur sauce et
chose impensable aujourd'hui ce fut
acceptée vous imaginez l'embrouillé de
faire ça aujourd'hui avec un one piece
naruto aucune chance ce qui provoque de
nos jours la colère des puristes ou
l'hilarité chez les autres ça dépend
directement de se venger et quels
secrets se cachent sous le voile de la
mariée
de nos jours le manga est toujours aussi
populaire surtout au japon où la licence
a été adapté en plusieurs produits
dérivés
une nouvelle série animée des zouaves et
des figurines et bien sûr des jeux vidéo
et même comble du truc en pachinko alors
et on sent vraiment le ca bon revenons à
notre jeu donc là ce battle où ken le
survivant comme vous préférez est tiré
de l'animé hokuto no ken 2 de 1987
animé qui n'a jamais été diffusé en
france le jeu sera distribué chez nous
comme dans les autres pays hors japon
c'est-à-dire sous le nom de l'as battle
est pas hokuto no ken shinsei qui matent
feud say it shows des soirées bolas
battles est très bien en fait au revoir
les corps qui explose sous l'impulsion
du petit doigt les giclées de sang et
bonjour à l'occidentalisation en effet
pour plus de coller à nos stéréotypes
les noms et aussi les couleurs des
personnages ont tous été modifié adios
chine nouveaux galets kenshiro qui se
battent dans le tokyo apocalyptique du
futur et bienvenue à alice à michaele
arzacq qui se battent dans montélimar
exit hulk hogan et bonjour hull tout
court il nous avait déjà fait le coup
avec hokuto no ken sur master system qui
est devenu black belt où tout l'univers
de ken cède sa place à un environnement
de karaté de schiphol bon voilà donc
notre bon vieux keynes à te laraque et
en guise de jaquette on se tape ben
affleck qui frappe un crs armés d'une
broche d'euros teaser en caoutchouc ok
c'est parti les doigts tél ok alors
chapitre 1 dacor ac le point b le pied
et c'est pour le souk et donc les sons
sont un peu bizarres jeux séparés mais
bon quand qu'elle lève la patte
[Musique]
je sais j'ai ce prétendu le jeu est un
beat them all dans toute sa splendeur il
n'ya pas à réfléchir on avance et on
frappe n'y a que peu de différence entre
le point et le pied sinon la longueur de
la portée du cou qui de temps à autre
selon les ennemis peut faire la
différence mais regardez ça mais c'est
ridicule la façon dont ils sont affectés
de l'écran je veux dire dans la version
japonaise s'était beaucoup plus fun
quand même je veux bien qu'on retire le
côté violent mais là on dira astérix
[Musique]
tous
on a une barre de puissance qui augmente
à force de botter des culs et il ya
trois repères dessus dès qu'on franchit
un repère kane ou plutôt à arzacq
explose sa veste et tous pectoraux
dehors devient tous mes nerfs et à la
puissance de ses coups décuplée sur le
papier c'est sympa mais ces nouveaux
coups répondent différemment aux
projectiles ce qui a quand même tendance
à faire chier une fois le premier niveau
passé on se retrouve sur une carte où on
choisit son itinéraire la stratégie est
vraiment inexistante dans le sens où on
doit accéder obligatoirement à certains
animaux pour leur grade et qu'elle est
aussi du fait que pour venir à bout de
certains boss il faut être en position
vénère ce qu'il est possible qu'en
accumulant les combats le prévôt jégo le
jeu se compose de quatre chapitres
divisé en trois sortes de niveau li
boshu niveau très chiant et les niveaux
mortels
bon je déconne ya les niveaux avec
bosses les niveaux style date forme et
les niveaux standards beat them all qui
constitue le coeur du jeu d'ailleurs à
ce propos les level sont tous les mêmes
le mot ennuis ne suffirait pas à décrire
ce sentiment de vieillesse qui m'envahit
quand je joue à l'as battle plus d'une
heure en fait vous avez tellement
l'impression de faire et refaire et
refaire et encore refaire le même niveau
en boucle qu'au bout d'un moment vous
avez vraiment le sentiment de vivre un
jour sans fin mais en vrai
c'est vrai
t
[Musique]
battus
je suis fan
[Applaudissements]
arte
[Musique]
t
alors quand la nuit de ce jeu vous
conduira aux portes du suicide vous ne
direz plus je me fais chier mais vous
dirai je me lasse battle au pardon mais
je
[Musique]
à
oudéa
moteur mais c'est en breton des pailles
il peut appeler c'est pas mal quand même
temps alors surtout penser à éliminer
tous les ennemis n'est qu'ils
apparaissent parce que si vous avancez
un peu trop vite ils vont prendre en
sandwich et le problème c'est que dès
que ce con de quais de toucher in the
block hercules élèves pour attendre que
ça s'arrête pour modé des coûts
[Musique]
quelques fois on tombe sur des niveaux
bourrés de pièges ou le doit monter et
descendre les étages en évitant toutes
sortes de projectiles qui vous foncent
dessus sans qu'il n'y ait personne à
l'autre bout on a des flèches des âges
des rochers et on doit s'en débarrasser
à coups de poing on doit aussi passer
dans des trous pour changer d'étagé il
faut faire attention car il ya des trous
qui vous ramène en arrière et alors faut
tous se retaper il faut sauter
par-dessus mais kane un saut trop court
pour faire un super saut il faut d'abord
presser le bouton saut et ensuite la
direction ce qu est l inverse de tous
les autres jeux inventés depuis 20 ans
ce jeu est vraiment un des plus durs
auquel j'ai jamais joué je sais que je
dis ça à chaque fois mais il a croyez
moi c'est vraiment vraiment dur on a une
seule barre de vie pour tous le jeu il
ya zéro continue on récupère de
l'énergie de manière totalement
aléatoire et on passe du sol là qu'un
puits de poules asthmatiques à des boss
qui sont quasiment imbattable il faut
connaître le jeu par coeur pour avancer
sans perdre de temps car on ne sait pas
à l'avancé ce qui nous attend dans un
niveau
ça ne sert à rien d'emprunter le chemin
le plus court car si vous n'avez pas
parler un personnage clé vous ne pourrez
pas aller plus loin
l'animation est dans ce jeu ce qu'il ya
de pire à la même époque
sortez des jeux de bien meilleure
qualité au niveau de l'animation ici on
a l'impression que les personnages ont
animé sur deux trams
regardez on dirait qu'il a un balai dans
le fion c'est pas ken le survivant assez
lord of the dance
pour pousser la tortue encore plus loin
il était possible de franchir certaines
zones sans avoir terminé certain niveau
c'est qu'il faut alors faire demi-tour
et repasser sur des niveaux qu'on a déjà
traversé quand même si un certain
sauvignon d'actifs pour refaire
intégralement votre barre d'énergie elle
est toujours aussi vides c'est qu'au
nord ils sont tous revenus
il faut recommencer depuis le début un
nombre incalculable de fois et
sérieusement ce game over bleu va vous
hanter toute votre vie en vous l'aurez
vu encore et encore et encore
[Musique]
ça y est c'est enfin le dernier boss
crever comme ils veulent
[Musique]
couteau de cuisine ou de salle à manger